il est tout rond jo il émerge à peine
d'une expérience unique un voyage au
plus près du peuple himbas de namibie un
peuple d'éleveurs nomades de ce périple
en compagnie de l'ethnologue solenn
bardet simon hureau en a fait une bande
dessinée intitulée rouge imba simon euro
qui est l'invité du 19/20 en duplex de
nos studios de tours
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous bonjour
alors vous qui êtes dessinateur de bd
installé en touraine on l'a dit pourquoi
vous être lancés dans cette aventure au
fin fond de la namibie
ça c'est le hasard des rencontres au gré
des festivals un jour se lève bardet
venu m'aborder en me demandant si ça
m'intéresserait de l'accompagner dans
son prochain voyage chez ses amis les
himbas qu'elle connaît depuis 25 ans
j'ai réfléchi un petit peu mais bon j'ai
accepté solenn bardet que l'on connaît
qui est noble avait notamment dans
l'émission rendez vous en terre inconnue
sur france télévisions vous avez donc
vécu pendant plusieurs semaines avec ce
peuple les himbas des namibiens qui
vivent encore de manière traditionnelle
comment ça s'est passé votre quotidien
avec eux eh bien c'était l'immersion est
totale et absolue la région dans
laquelle ils vivent est tellement reculé
que
extrêmement difficile d'accès elle est
semi désertique
il n'ya pas l'électricité donc on était
en camping en fait avec les provisions
chez les himbas qui peuvent pas non plus
nous accueillir étant donné la fragilité
de leur équilibre de vie
donc on est avec eux mais voilà dans la
tente à côté à côté du village et le
quotidien a été rythmée par les
l'accompagnement du troupeau points
d'eau les tâches quotidiennes secoué la
calebasse pour faire le lait caillé
c'est aller chercher le bois pour le feu
et on le voit les famines bas vive par
exemple encore de manière traditionnelle
sont recouvertes de cette offre de pouce
de rouge
j'imagine que pour vous au dessinateur
ce doit être un bonheur à mettre en
images
ah oui non c'est fabuleux elles sont à
la fois pictural et sculptural
parce qu'en plus de cette couleur rouge
elles ont des multitudes de parures tout
à fait étonnante de cuir de peau de
coquillages le tout recouvert de 2,7
ce mélange de graisses de pigments au
creux rouge donc c'est absolument
magnifique et en effet donc tout le
toute leur vie est rythmée par la
tradition à commencer par cette allure
physique et vestimentaire est ce qu'il
est une spécificité lorsqu'on est
dessinateur de bd de rendre compte d'un
voyage comme celui ci alors moi sur
place je ne faisais pas de bande
dessinée je griffonnais dans mes carnets
toute la journée autant que possible et
le plus rapidement possible parce que la
nuit tombe très vite là bas 18 heures il
ya plus de lumière et comme il n'y a pas
d'électricité ni un lampadaire
on se retrouve un peu coincé ou alors
c'est à la lampe frontale mais au bout
du compte tous les croquis que j'ai fait
sur place ça a été la matière du projet
de bande dessinée qui qui nous ont servi
ensuite qu'on a utilisé ou pas mais mais
c'était une mise dans l'ambiance
graphiquement puisque finalement le
l'ensemble de la bande dessinée se fait
ensuite en atelier chez moi avec avec un
message aussi porté par vous et solenn
bardet qu'on peut malgré les différences
entre les peuples tous vivre ensemble
finalement absolument absolument elle
elle les connaît depuis 25 ans et ce
sont ses meilleurs amis
l allée des relations encore plus proche
avec ses amis et sa famille bach
quasiment qu'avec des gens qu'elle aime
les gens qu'elle côtoie en france est en
effet les modes de vie sont extrêmement
différents absolument incomparable pour
autant dès qu'on franchit le cap de
cette différence immédiate et qu'on
apprend à se connaître et bien on se
rend compte qu'on est tous très inégaux
merci merci beaucoup simon hureau je
vous êtes tourangeau dessinateur de bd
de cette bande dessinée sorties de la
semaine dernière rouge imba vous serez
d'ailleurs je le signale présent au
festival bd boum de blois en fin de
semaine merci d'avoir été l'invité de ce
journal